intermountain healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment want to remind you
about the importance of making sure you
and your loved ones have a primary care
provider here's why
the reason it's important to have a
primary care provider or family doctor
is because they really are
your partner in your health care journey
across your lifetime
they work with you to
really manage all aspects of your health
when you're both well
and in times when you need them during
illness or injury you may not know when
you need to see a specialist and when
you don't but your primary care
physician will and so the relationship
you develop with them
is going to be so helpful in determining
when you need to come in and who you
need to see and when they really want to
ensure that they're partnering with you
and building a team with you that's
right for you and your family if you're
having a life-threatening emergency or
an injury
we want you to call 9-1-1 and we want
you to know that emergency departments
are there to help you in times of crisis
or need
but the relationship that you develop
with a primary care physician is going
to be essential because throughout your
lifetime there are going to be times
when you have questions and you don't
know the best place to be seen
your primary care physician is going to
be able to help answer those questions
and sometimes it may be that you need to
be seen urgently or emergently in an
urgent care
or in emergency department
but your primary care physician can
manage a lot of those things within the
office setting itself
and so we want to ensure that you have a
primary care doctor that you can call on
the phone or send a message to online
and ask those questions about what's
right for me right now sometimes that's
urgent and you need to be seen quickly
they'll be able to tell you that there
are other times where they know they can
best manage that in the clinic
themselves
also what a primary care provider can do
is really think about what questions you
have in the broader context of your
health and what other resources may be
necessary down the road to prevent that
from happening again
and so it gets back to that notion of
building a relationship with a primary
care provider who that you who you can
trust and who you can pick up the phone
and call or send an email to to get
those questions answered
and that you know that person's there
for you when you're healthy but also
perhaps in times of crisis or in
questions
it's also important that you know
you can
choose your primary care provider and we
encourage you to go online and look at
reviews
or look at our internet site where you
can search for providers that may have
experience in
treating patients like you you can also
search for providers by gender or by
languages spoken so that we are ensuring
that you have someone that can meet your
needs and your family's needs together
thank you to intermountain healthcare
for sponsoring this segment head to
intermountain healthcare.org
nevada for more information we'll be
right back